et pour lever toute ambiguïté je réponds
à la question le pacte de solidarité at
il pour origine une revendication portée
par des associations homosexuelles
eh bien oui bien sûr mais qui mieux que
des homosexuels pouvaient à partir de
leur expérience de solitude de rejet de
mépris faire le diagnostic des
difficultés qui ronge notre société pour
bâtir un projet chacun et chacune
d'entre nous pourra se retrouver lui ses
enfants ses parents à un moment ou à un
autre de sa vie car finalement nous ne
reconnaissons ici qu'une communauté la
république
pas dans la tradition de la présidence
de sortir de sa neutralité mais je tiens
à vous dire madame que vous avez exprimé
récemment le souhait de dire que dans le
passé vous auriez souhaité être ici pour
votre et certaines lois je me réjouis
d'être à la place je suis aujourd'hui